racism makes us confused sometimes I
actually don't use the word I don't use
the word racism because it's so often
misunderstood being young growing up in
Britain overt racism was casual but you
kind of got used to the fact that in any
kind of public arena
you could be racially abused terminology
for a long time Blacky yeah it was cool
I mean that one's all I'm talking about
there you're proper blacks you know the
ways that was born in a jungle united i
mean don't tell me they're educated off
whatever stilly in each other so
sometimes to understand racism we need
personal experiences about three years
ago I was walking through White Hart
Lane station I heard someone shout very
loudly the n-word is a whether I don't
use I thought at first it was someone
listening to an Eminem song or something
and they were you know thinking that
they were jay-z so I just kept walking
the word was shouted again and who do
you think you are
I know who I am but so I looked around
to see what was going on in case it
wasn't directed towards me I didn't
think instinctively that it was and it
was directed towards me there was a
woman in a-flat looking out of the flat
and she was screaming and yelling at me
I said why are you shouting at me and
why are you shouting the n-word because
that's what you people call yourself
I said you people this is a woman who
doesn't know me and has never seen me
before and yet she felt empowered not
twenty years ago not thirty years ago
to use such terminology to refer to me
and that's to show you that those over
forms of racism still exist
I I work with a lot of white
middle-class people who like to feel
that they're not racist sexist
homophobic and all these other things
but they are they are but they are
instinctively and and they they do it
not knowing that they're doing it and
when I'm there they still censor
themselves on issues of ethnicity or
issues that they feel that I would be
sensitive about does that mean that
they've changed it means at least that
they're thinking about them in a certain
kind of way because I'm in their social
space if I wasn't in their social space
perhaps they wouldn't be thinking about
it that's the problem with racism even
in human interactions one is
second-guessing oneself as to did that
happen because of color did that happen
because of ethnicity I like to go to the
cinema and watch films I don't think
what I'm enjoying that film all those
millions of people throughout the world
that can't see I have privilege I have
the privilege of sight that privilege of
sight means that I don't think about
those people that don't have the same
privilege does that make me prejudiced I
think in a way it does it makes me
prejudiced against those that cannot see
but it's a kind of privilege and
Prejudice that seems natural to me
because the world is effectively made
for those that can see that's the thing
about prejudice it feels normal
I'm the only way that you eradicate
racism is by changing people's beliefs
and ideas and the only way you get to do
that is through education and
information you can punish people for
their ideas or their beliefs but you
might not change their views and ideas I
think you need to change people's views
and ideas not punish them
you